and while berks and fauci try their
hands at historical fiction team biden
lashing out at states that aren't bowing
down to the wishes of the medical cartel
alabama's governor said that she's going
to go forward with her plans to
remove the masked mandate the governors
know that they're not helping the cause
that they're actually weighing down the
cause and
that they may think it's a popular thing
to do i don't think that's the case i
think people want to be told
what the what the what the truth of the
matter is
the truth of the matter joining me now
former white house chief of staff mark
meadows
uh mark they are clearly
trying to diminish states rights even as
we see the true numbers
coming out of texas that completely
belie the point they're making
well you're right the the numbers that
we're seeing uh laura
honestly do not support the the biden
policy that we have coming out
you know what we saw from dr burks and
dr fauci
was really a political statement it was
blame shifting
and trying to suggest that policies that
they were part of
uh somehow uh that president trump is
to blame for that when really he's the
one that should have
credit for actually making sure that
millions of americans lives
uh and millions across the world were
saved because of the vaccine that
he actually made sure got developed but
the other
other thing in a joe biden world laura
in a joe biden world
you don't need an id for voting
you don't need an id to come across our
southern border
but somehow we're going to have a
vaccine passport
in order to carry on your normal lives
you know this is all about trying to
make
d.c make the decisions for local
communities and it's just not what
america is all about
mark i know you know this but dr fauci
was actually in the cnn special trying
to take
credit and essentially for the vaccines
but you were
in the room when when he was throwing
cold water on the idea that the vaccines
were going to be ready
last fall correct am i stating that
correctly well you're 100
correct dr fauci didn't mention vaccines
for the vast majority
of the time leading up to actually when
we got the vaccine
but he's trying to take credit for
something that
even he told president trump was not
possible for two
three maybe four years that it would
take much longer than this
and yet the president insisted on all of
us staying
engaged in making sure that we got the
vaccine done and we have that today
because of great companies
and great leadership in president trump
here's a little more from dr burke's
very melodramatic
reading and airing of the grievances
mark watch
you were the covet coordinator and no
one's uh no one around you is is wearing
masks
that must have that must have felt like
you were being marginalized that people
really weren't listening to you
i was marginalized every day i mean
that is no question on i would say
majority of the people in the white
house
did not take this seriously
did you get invited to the sorority
mixer there mark what's up
well listen we we listened to dr burks
she was listened to every day and now
what she's doing is trying to change
history to suggest that somehow
her input was not valued and listened to
when we
listen to it each and every day as she
jumps into the private sector she wants
a softer landing perhaps mark
you all were apparently very scary to
her too she was very
frightened or basically frightened
that's what she said
uh mark thank you for being here tonight